[Music]
[Applause]
we'll check in with Peter King football
morning in America columnist think he
leaves Wednesday for Frankford Germany
it'll be Kansas City and the
Dolphins phone calls we'll get to those
coming up as well Mercedes Benz the EV
is not just extraordinary it's extra
easy and the vehicle's all electric the
feeling all Mercedes the choic is all
yours learn more mbusa.com
EQ let's bring in Peter King who joins
us on the program Pete where do you want
to start what do you think the biggest
headline of the NFL weekend is well I
don't want to start with Giants and jets
because the game set football back to
1919 which is a year before the NFL was
invented um you know Dan I think
probably to
me
longterm the most interesting thing that
happened this weekend is that Joe burrow
and the Bengals continued to reaffirm
that they will be a factor in January
and perhaps February and I thought
burrow played absolutely great you know
with Joe Montana watching from a box
upstairs he had a Joe Montana day
completed uh 88% of his
throws you know did not throw a pick and
he had a play that I talked about my
column this morning that is just a play
only the great ones will make at least
in my opinion he changed the course of
this game with a shake of his shoulder
and a throw to Jamar Chase for a
touchdown in the fourth quarter that
clinch the game and look three weeks ago
we all thought Joe burrow might might be
plagued by this calf injury the whole
year but he looks as good as he ever has
especially yesterday okay but the ners
feel like they're in a little bit of
trouble yeah what's the biggest
issue well first of all uh you know and
and again look there's no question that
Brock P's an issue is he plagued in any
way by uh you know the concussion he got
in the Monday night game should he have
played yesterday all I know is that you
know the NFL is very big on these
independent neurologists this is not a
49ers physician clearing Joe burrow or
clearing Brock pie excuse me this is an
independent physician clearing them and
so you know you just have to take it
like okay maybe burrow maybe Brady is
off and and all that but I think as big
as Brock P's problems have been in the
last five quarters where is this
suffocating
defense that the 49ers should have right
now they shouldn't be allowing 31 points
to anybody at home uh or or anywhere
quite honestly and to me that the
defense is as big or bigger a problem
right now than uh than the
quarterback what puzzles you the most
post about DeShaun Watson in the brown
situation that we are Midway through the
second season since he signed this
incredible contract the the
haslams have already doled out
million in the span of 17 months to
deshun Watson and yet Dan you me the
Browns Deshawn Watson's mother for
crying out or whoever we have no idea if
he's going to be the player ever again
that he was when he was in
Houston this isn't just a little time
where he has been in a slump or hasn't
played well and now obviously it's
exacerbated by his shoulder injury but
you know Dan they the Cleveland Browns
could get to the end of this season and
be 40% finished with this contract and
not have a good idea about whether in
trading three middle ones you know picks
between 10 and 20 and paying Deshawn
Watson the biggest fully guaranteed
contract in NFL history they could get
to the end of this year and not have any
idea if he's their long-term answer at
quarterback Titans find their
quarterback yesterday I think so he
throws really a majestic deep ball I I
was so impressed with Will Levis uh and
you know the Deep balls he throws and
Dan I think after the game he sort of
Illustrated why you the Titans one of
the reasons the Titans are excited about
him he wasn't really in celebratory mode
he said how much time is it I got 12
minutes to celebrate this game and we we
play Thursday and I got to be ready to
go so I kind of like hearing that out of
a young player and we'll see but his
debut was the best de debut first game
of a rookie in a long time Peter King
football morning in America columnist
and contributor to NBC Sports back to
the Titans I'm wondering if you have
your quarterback are you now more likely
to trade Derrik Henry because the future
is if it's will Levis Derrick Henry's
probably not going to be a big part of
that future moving
forward well first of all Dan derck
Henry turns 30 in January and it's
highly unlikely that when he's a free
agent this off season that the Titans
are going to Pony up big money to keep
him now if he doesn't get any offers uh
out there because nobody wants to pay
big money to a 30-year-old running back
maybe he comes back to Tennessee no
Bridges have been burned but my only
point about this is the Tennessee Titans
as of right now are going to have two
picks in about the top
110 of this draft in 2024 this is a team
clearly in rebuilding mode and they just
don't have the volume and the quality of
draft choices to make a big impact next
year in April so if I'm
them uh I would really try everything in
my power if I'm Rand carthon and Mike
Vel to get a day two draft choice for
Derrick Henry uh to go somewhere for the
last 10 games of this season and maybe
win a game or two for pick a team
Baltimore Dallas I who Whoever has a
running back need or perceived running
back need but I would really be trying
to move Derrick Henry I don't know that
that that Mike Vel is of the same
mindset after he saw his team play well
and win a game against a division leader
yesterday tell me how the game in
Germany came about with the Chiefs
Chiefs wanted to play there and uh they
there were only a couple of of opponents
I was reading in your column today so
how do how does that come about with the
schedu makers well a lot of people in
the last couple of weeks have been
saying why in the world would the NFL
export one of the 10 best games out of
272 on its schedule for
2023 to Germany where it's going to be
played at 9:30 in the morning and the
rating will not be as good as the game
let's just say and you know it's a very
very good question you have to start
with the fact a Kansas City wanted to
play over there b uh the NFL they they
had nine home games and so T the NFL
likes to schedule teams so that they can
keep their eight home games and then
play their ninth home game uh
internationally when they can do that so
this is a year that Kansas City has nine
home games they had a terrific schedule
at home and you know they've got
Philadelphia at home Buffalo at home
Cincinnati at home and they had Miami at
home so when they went to schedule all
of these games back in March April early
may they just said wow we got so many
choices with the Kansas City Chiefs but
we do not want to export Cincinnati it
could be an AFC Championship preview we
don't want to export Buffalo they're
already going to go over and play uh uh
in London next year this year and they
really didn't want to have a Super Bowl
rematch at 9:30 in the morning in
Germany with Philadelphia it really came
down to two games either Detroit or uh
Miami and I think that there was some
thought inside the league that listen
Detroit has earned its way into a richer
schedule this year and they took a
chance the NFL took a chance in
scheduling Detroit for the opening game
and it turned out to be an incredible
chance you know for them because it was
a game for four quarters the Lions won
it got a huge number and now they'll go
overseas and NFL network is jumping for
joy to have this game I know that
there's NFL MBA P odds and it's always a
quarterback but the offensive player of
the year is not
quarterbacks tyri Hill can you put him
on the short list of MVP candidates like
he's the leading candidate right now
according to DraftKings for offensive
player of the year yeah I think Tyreek
Hill and AJ
Brown uh are both first of all they
Tyreek Hill AJ Brown Christian mcaffrey
Midway at the SE near the M season's
midpoint are the offensive player of the
year favorites I would think um and I
think all of them could get some run in
terms of the MVP as well Dan right now
at this moment I probably probably would
take AJ Brown for a very simple
reason you know if you think about it
and I wrote this this morning do you
realize AJ Brown is on a six game game
Run that is better than any six-game run
that Jerry Rice ever
had and you know so who knows if that
continues you don't have to vote for you
don't vote for these things after eight
weeks of football you vote you vote for
them after 18 weeks of football and I
have a feeling there's going to be a lot
more clarity in two months than there is
right now when I think it's very muddled
at the top there when we have these
Standalone games everybody has an
opinion there's a referendum on the
Raiders or the Lions tomorrow morning
what do you think our referendum is
going to be either on the Lions or the
Raiders I think people will be asking
you know do the Raider I I think the
lions are going to win this game um and
if as expected the Lions do win this
game I think there are ways that you
lose games that can look a lot different
and the way that the Raiders lost at
Chicago you know to Tyson bent uh last
week that would really bother me a
second straight game like that and I
think there are going to be significant
questions about Josh McDaniels moving
forward great to talk to you as always
Pete safe travels to Germany hey thanks
a lot Dan have a great day and I look
forward to hearing about the beer that
you have over there in your column on
Monday oh make sure that I'll do a Dan
Patrick beer of the week thank you Peter
that's Peter King football morning in
America columnist and
nbcsports.com